Schmidlapp hamdulillah greetings of
peace assalamualaikum Eeyore how are you
like a lot the litigants here are the
part of the ask a Muslim and you're
meeting a Muslim and you actually at one
point you were in a Muslim and you
became a Muslim and we want people to it
we want to encourage people to reflect
to think what's the purpose of life
we're only here for a short amount of
time and playing all those video games
and partying and playing and you know
wasting time he's not answering the
question and when death comes is too
late is bye-bye and then you're gonna be
stuck you know you wake up even out of
way if you're not waking up now at that
point is too late you woke up you woke
up actually you started to research
you're from a Christian background and
then you became an agnostic and we see
this a lot people going through every
walk of life every way of life and then
you know they get fed up with these
man-made ideas and bludgeons and and
then they come to the way that's from
the Creator Islam you were no exception
what happened you know I mean it taken
longer than the time we have but pretty
much I was raised Christian for about 20
years of my life and I got to the point
at the age of 14 I started asking a lot
of questions you know to my pastor
doesn't make sense how is Jesus son of
God if he really is a son how can God
allow his son to go through this pain
and torture you know I would give my
life for my son and protect my son how
could God do this and you know these
tell me you're too young it's really
deep it's a lot of information and as I
got older
the questions became tougher and they
just you know couldn't answer them I'm
sitting around 18 19
God Almighty made something happened my
life that my father it all came back
into it and into internalized and
started to tell me about Islam
I told I'm not a Muslim just cuz you're
Muslim as in my own research
your mother was Christian your father
was Muslim yeah yeah and so my father
you know I told my I'm not gonna be
Muslim just cuz you're Muslim and that's
what I recommend for everybody they have
to do their own research you know just
because your father or your mother is a
certain religion doesn't mean you have
to be that way you know you should be
you God Almighty gave you a brain
intellectually you have to do your own
research because at the end of the day
on the day of judgment no one will be
with you on the day of judgment it'll be
you and God one on one your pastor your
father your mother your grandmother no
one will be able to protect you and it's
really important to read about it your
do your own research ask most some about
Islam that's what I did you know I did
research about every religion actually
like Buddhism Hinduism
you know Islam Christianity you know
Judaism and at the end of the day Islam
makes 100% common sense and it's really
answered all my questions that I had as
a Christian so it was really really
riveting and amazing you have a hard
time sometimes many of the challenges
people face by trying to just you know
imitate the way of Jesus Moses Abraham
becomes you know kind of opposite to the
culture today you get you have more of a
easy time fitting in if you're following
Lady Gaga googoo $0.50 and jay-z is just
all good but if you want to imitate the
best of creation Jesus Moses Abraham
Mohammed peace and mercy be upon him
probably then it's a problem you know
what I mean so you get a beard you know
you look like a Muslim and you look like
Jesus and people start calling you all
this terrorist right how do you have you
- have you dealt with this at all how do
you do yeah for sure for sure I mean
especially in the society in this
environment for the first maybe I mean
I've been Muslim for ten years first
seven years six seven years I wasn't
really practicing like practicing
practicing just because you know society
the you know society is it pulls you
away from consciousness of God and
wanting to get closer to God and who is
he and finding out more and worshiping
him the way you're supposed to you know
like you said they're insulated gaga and
clubs and music and the devil is doing
really really good job you know of
pulling people away from God but um once
you find that that hole once you get you
know you you you grab the Rope of Allah
she says you know the Rope that will
never deteriorate it really brings you
in and it knowledge is the best thing to
bring somebody closer to Allah you know
that's why the scholars fear Allah the
most because they have the most
knowledge you know they they know what's
going on and it's tough but once you
once you once I would never go back to
what I what I used to be ever I mean I
tell people all the time you know that I
call you know even with some of my
Muslim family members like come on man
just you know trim the beard a little
bit you know it's a little a little
extreme I tell them I don't care if you
give me everything in the world I'll
never touch my beard you put a suitcase
in front of me million dollars twenty
thirty hundred million dollar
I'll never touch it because between me
and Allah that's you know that that's
between me and God the Almighty Creator
so I would never give anything up to go
back to how I used to be I'm very happy
that that God has guided me to where I
am now in my life what would you say
when people try to tribute extremism or
radicalism or terrorism to Islam what do
you tell them I'll tell I'm looking to
look into the Quran you know just read
about it you know I mean we we greet
each other with peace you know we say
as-salamu alaikum may peace be unto you
and you know the other person would say
wa alaikum as-salaam and upon you may
may be peace I mean it is a peaceful
religion you know I mean of course we
stand up for our rights we defend our
family if we have to we defend ourselves
if we have to if it comes to it but I
mean the Prophet was a prophet of mercy
peace upon him Allah tells us the
Almighty Creator that on his throne he
said in my my mercy comes before my
anger so before he gets angry his mercy
comes first which is what he wants us to
be merciful and Islam is I mean is far
far from terrorism or or or violence
outside of what is mandated it's it's
nothing near anything of that nature
compared to how you were living back
then you said you would never go back to
that lifestyle what kind of lifestyle
was that that you would never go back to
an empty lifestyle my heart was empty
and this is why you see suicidal rates
going up this is why I see these rich
people these millionaires and these
rappers and his artists at the end of
the day in their hearts they're empty
their hearts are nowhere happy nowhere
near being happy Islam is the true
happiness if you are connected with your
Creator this is the most important thing
so I wasn't connected with my Creator
back in the day now I'm connected with
him we pray five times a day revives
that feeling of being connected it
really it really helps you go on with
your day and it's a beautiful feeling I
would never give that feeling up because
once you're not connected with the
Creator life becomes useless and
pointless we see that a lot I mean every
14 seconds somebody is committing
suicide and for one person that commits
suicide there's 25 that have tried and
it's a growing epidemic between
from 15 years of age of 24 so you're
dead on I mean this is something people
on xanax on Prozac on all sorts of drugs
but they live in a nice nicest houses
and actually you know you know what the
day on which suicide is committed the
most is on holiday Monday Monday
guess why you know the party you're
kicking it on the weekend think your
problems gonna go away but you come back
to them even stronger when the hangover
is off right yeah it's it's amazing and
then but you those suicidal Tennessee I
mean obviously depression could hit
anybody but you don't when you have it's
long you don't fall into despair you
know what I mean there's always hope you
follow me there's a forgiveness of God
the mercy of God you live in purpose you
know purpose instead of just living for
your lusts and desires and and and now
when you say that I mean most people who
are out there if they're tuning in for
the first time who are bankrupt in the
soul I mean they can get rich in the
heart by by doing what what was the
simple things that you have to do to
become a Muslim I mean it's easy I mean
like I said I'm a lot of the question
that I had as a Christian were answered
as a Muslim you know who is Jesus what
is his relationship to God may peace be
upon him you know so this is realizing
that he can only be a prophet and mighty
Messenger of God and that he is only a
creation of God he cannot be linked to
the creator he's not a creator and he's
not part of the Creator he is a part of
the creation so that accepting that is
the first thing and then after that
understanding you know looking at the
Quran the Quran is a miraculous book
that was impossible for this man named
Prophet Muhammad peace upon him 1400
years ago to have come up with this book
by himself it's just it's an literally
impossible especially because he was
illiterate and then you compare the
Bible Quran there are many things in the
in the Bible that point to Islam you
know or Jesus Christ reach upon him was
asked in the Bible what is the most
important commandment he said worship
the Lord our God the Lord is one if you
ask any Muslim this is what we believe
in to worship the Lord our God he's one
yes simple and is the same message that
Muhammad peace upon him taught
scientific miracles in the Quran
impossible for him to have known
mountains having roots in the ground
universe is continuously growing
expanding and so on and so forth as many
many
miracles that is impart and that's what
actually pulled me to Islam scientific
miracles or facts in the Quran stated by
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him 1400
years ago this is what pulled me in' I
told myself when I read this book I was
like you know I remember still reading
it like it was yesterday
read this book and it talks about the
brief Illustrated guide a very powerful
book and when it said that you know goes
with embryonic development in the in the
mother's womb I open up the Quran to the
chapters that it was stating and I was
really reading it in the book I didn't
believe that it was really in a book I
was reading and I was like wow this is
really in the book so I have kept going
through the book and I at the end of the
book I said this is impossible it's
impossible for this man to have known
all these things with the little
technology that they had 1400 years ago
I mean cars were just invented a hundred
years ago so I mean it's impossible it
just makes sense you put all that other
superficial stuff to the side you know
maybe you're on your viet you're on the
VIP list you're about to get into the
nightclub you're gonna have social event
that party and it is party and play and
many people they're just asleep but
anyone who really you know seeks for
more what you're saying it makes sense
or what else you just turn to dust you
die and that's it we're going somewhere
and ignoring the fact how do you do you
have do you see this new growing trend
with this whole new atheism movement
because you said you became an agnostic
now what what do you say to someone
who's suffering with that dilemma
I mean atheism I think is just kind of
like sort of a cop-out you know because
any atheist I really want them to deeply
think about their shoes about their the
roof on their house about the watch in
their hands even the ring on their
fingers every single thing that's
created has a purpose and we are much
more higher degree of Technology if you
if you would have a creation that has to
have a purpose you know the shoes
protect your feet the roof protects you
from the rain the ring symbolizes that
you're married the watch tells you the
time what about us what's our purpose
you know if you for you to just say oh
my purpose is to live a good life well
then you're missing out on the bigger
purpose of that yes it is but our
purpose in Islam is to identify that
there's a creator and to worship Him to
be great to be grateful for everything
that he's given us and to love him with
all our heart and to work hard to try to
get into paradise through his mercy of
course but also through our actions
proving to him that we truly believe in
love him so I would tell the atheists
read the Quran it is not possible for a
person to open up the Quran with an open
heart and be asking God to guide them to
the truth and they read the whole Quran
and they still don't believe in it I
mean it's just it's just not possible
the Quran is filled with so many things
that just pull you in and make you
understand that it has to be the truth
as for the truth I like that it's a
cop-out because I mean who you kidding
everybody believes in the creator it
just doesn't make sense that you don't
because you just covering this up they
did a a poll a research study from the
Oxford University and this is science
now they did 57 researchers 20 different
22 different studies 40 different
countries and they concluded that belief
in the Creator is something natural
disbelief is acquired you got to work to
cover it up the fifth of what we have
inside of us that innate nature to
believe and common-sense arguments look
at your shoes look at your socks look at
your house ring everything has a purpose
but the human being doesn't have a
purpose that doesn't make sense that's a
cop-out you know there's a creator and
it's not makes the most sense because
it's calling you to only worship the
Creator and if you have any other
questions asked who a Muslim as to
Muslims calm you guys have a website
here also you guys also not the only
delivering the message of peace purpose
but also spreading the food out there
tell us a little bit about your about
your work which you guys do yeah you can
check us out on Facebook we usually post
on Facebook ask Muslim comm and Facebook
page we post a lot when we're gonna feed
the poor Friday Saturday and Sundays
Columbus Ohio to 773 Cleveland Avenue
we're here you know feeding the poor
it's a really beautiful thing we've
already had some shadows through this
but you know I think this is what
Muslims are supposed to do we're
supposed to take care of the community
you know we're supposed to take care of
those who are in need and Allah subhana
Allah says you know like he loves those
who care for others you know it's not
just me me me me me it's about us it's
about how we work together as a
community so Hum Dil on one of the
brothers you know we got a food pantry
now started the first one in Columbus
Ohio by Muslims and it's going it's
going amazing it's growing a lot since
it's beautiful thank you so much exactly
what he said iPhone iMac I mean
no no it's about we it's about us as a
community growing giving back and that's
what the Muslims are doing the Muslims
one who simply submitted a crater not
the creation thank you for being with us
here on the Deen show and we'll see you
next time tune in every week same time
same channel so I'll make them subscribe
if you haven't already peace be with you